hey welcome back to another episode of
VFX RS react okay
hey what's up everybody we have a very
special podcast today because we want to
teach you how to build your very own
open source equivalent of a one wheel
which we like to call a vesque
our personal preference is to call it
vesque that definitely didn't come from
anywhere online or anyone else started
here now people listen to this be like
well I don't need to build a one-wheeler
or have any desire to build a one-wheel
should I just get out this podcast which
I reply no wait wait listen not only are
we going to talk about how to build a
vest we're also going to share the
stories how we built our own vesks
because Ren and I
have done it we have our Wheels right
here and they're super cool
yeah and they're super awesome and
building them was quite a journey so we
built these like two and a half months
ago-ish around that time it was like
mid-july or so I just broke in my hand
and we built these things it was around
the same time we did the previous
podcast about one Wheels which was all
about my broken hand and and various
other one wheel related things
um there has since been uh wakes from
that that podcast and I know uh
I know one-wheel related stuff is not
generally super I guess I don't know
what the interesting applicable to most
of our viewers so this is going to be a
little bit more of a Taylor podcast kind
of like that a little inside baseball
but it's very important to us and I feel
like uh people like here and you talk
about what you're passionate about
friend yeah and so one of the reasons
why I wanted to have you on this podcast
Jan is because the three of us at least
within our own core group of friends
like we're the three that ride the most
like we're the ones who are always down
for rides and we usually do it like once
a week maybe more usually at like 9 00
p.m at night until like one in the
morning depends on how how meet up in a
mountain somewhere how far I've been
traveling that week but yeah yeah but
yeah no we we often uh use the term
three boards kateers
um what we've never used that term we
have used it every single hi
he uses the informal phrase of we which
means me
years ago with uh Yumi Clinton cliff and
we call ourselves the four boardsmen
since then we've expanded to well over a
dozen of us like probably closer to 20
but there's usually like eight of us
that really like respond to the text
threads anymore the the core writing
group and then honestly most uh most
rides we do are are at night uh just
because if if you don't know La is
pretty uh uh uh strict about their their
single track uh electric devices on
single track uh
um uh uh parts of the city so we tend to
do it all at night and uh yeah usually
at 9 30 p.m on a Tuesday you can only
get us three on board uh maybe one or
two other people uh yeah yeah so we
one-wheel a lot I would say there is
nothing else in the world I am obsessed
with more than the one wheel and one
Wheeling like
seriously I I thought I would have
gotten tired of this by now but the
opposite has happened I just continue to
get more and more into it to the point
that I went to float life Fest for a
second year in a row which is basically
a giant event festival for one Wheels
like five or six hundred one wheelers
showed up to Arkansas freaking
Bentonville Arkansas just to hang out
one wheel around do some races and
whatnot and it was the best time ever
and people are probably wondering like
what's so great about one wheels and
there's there's a lot of reasons but
kind of the main reason is it's a really
great mode of transportation especially
in a city that can handle things like
mountains and like mountain bike single
track it's got power it's got a lot of
range and the thing is like when you get
to a place you can pick it up and carry
it with you inside which is big but it's
really especially yeah you don't have to
deal with what a bicycle would be or
worry about theft or anything I I use
Metro a lot in La
um being able to just pick up your means
of Transport go into the Metro yeah uh
get halfway across the city and then use
your electric skateboard to do the rest
of it it's incredible there's no there's
no device outside of an electric
unicycle that'll get you uh through all
that uh terrain as quickly but even then
I'd argue that a one wheel is more
Nimble for City riding than an EUC sure
you also look way cooler way cooler
definitely do not disagree with that
something about that side profile that
snowboarder profile just I mean every I
thinking that that I agree with you on
that front Nico that like it a one wheel
is more versatile than an EUC electric
unicycle we call them eucs uh but just
when I really start to believe that I
see someone do the craziest stuff on an
EUC I'm like oh wow I mean so when I say
rehearsal I mean like when you're
waiting at the corner for the light to
change you can be on the one wheel and
standing on it you can do a little
Dooley Loop and you know like on the UC
you have to like get off it or have
incredibly good balance uh also if
you're gonna go if you're gonna go on to
the like the Metro uh uh I'm not going
to take an EUC down a flight of stairs
they're like you know 60 pounds or
something I where's a one wheel even
though the GTS and the vests are not
light by any stretch of the imagination
you can still pick them up yeah it's
it's not going to require you to take
the ACs have like a little handle that
fold up and then you can just walk it
like a like a luggage thing sure so so
one of those are great is what we're
trying to get to yes yes you know
because say comparing a one wheel to an
electric skateboard which have like the
smaller Wheels four of them and and you
know I wrote a boosted board for two
years before I got a one wheel I loved
him and I cannot go back because the
versatility of the diameter of the tire
it allows it to go over all huge amount
of types of terrain a huge variety of
terrain rocks bumps going up curbs going
off curbs going off big curbs like you
can't really do any of that on an
electric skateboard and so
I think we're all on the same page of
that like this is the most versatile
personal electric vehicle you can
possibly have yep so we've been waiting
for future motion to come out with an
updated version of a one wheel for a
long time and they finally came out with
a step up uh this past winter or so
which was the GT now you know what I was
hoping for in a one wheel the GT didn't
quite go all the way to the point of
what I was looking for but like I'm like
the kind of guy who's looking for like
the high-end electric mountain bike and
most people aren't looking for that
right you know it's like I want a tire
that I want to one wheel I can take me
up a staircase and most people like look
we'll just settle for like a steep hill
and that's funny like that it counts for
like 99 of people sure and I feel like
future motion made a great one wheel on
the GT that actually is very capable but
it's not like the extremely high-end
extreme sports version of the thing that
I was looking for and likewise there's
people that like doing tricks there's
people that like doing all-terrain
writing there's a whole bunch of
different people getting into the sport
now imagine only having like 2 two bikes
in existence and one company that makes
them because future motion has the
patent on one wheels or at least the the
design of them when you say one Wheels I
need to be specific here it is a brand
name the term one wheel is a brand name
for future motions devices what we have
here yeah trademarked what we have here
on you know the table in front of Ren
that is not a one wheel that is a vesk
and we are going to confuse the terms at
times and just yeah because it's so easy
just to call it a one-wheel we call I
mean we call it the greatest because
that's we the name is vesque it stands
for better electric speed controller
Vetter is the name of the dude who
invented the open source electronic
speed controller system
um some I think it's also called like
variable electronic speed controls it
doesn't matter v-e-s-c ESC
is a very common uh age-old type of
controller for Motors it what we call it
is the name same thing is like
people forget that the one wheel is made
by a company called future motion sure
and not by a company called
sure so Wren why did you build a vesque
especially as somebody who owns two GTS
well uh
because I am an addict and uh I need not
I mean you're not wrong okay yeah
exactly I
I'm at a point in my life where I can
afford a toy like this because this is
more like having one one wheel I
wouldn't call a toy I would call that a
vehicle sure having multiple one Wheels
is a bit indulgent and I'm at a point in
my life where I'm prepared for that
Indulgence uh you have abundance you're
just uh so for years we rode the one
wheel XR which is an incredible device
incredible device incredible but it was
out for years and you know 2021 is
starting to come to a close and
everyone's like man are they not going
to announce like an updated version of
the one wheel like we want more power we
want more range the last thing they
updated or the last thing they released
was the Pint which is a smaller more
mainstream more affordable version of a
one wheel but now what we're looking for
yeah and it's also worth mentioning we
had modded our XRS I was gonna say there
was an entire modding uh Community where
you could get aftermarket almost
anything on on the board from from rails
to to batteries batteries probably being
the the main the the biggest jump ahead
because you could get a lot more range
out of it a lot more power and so on and
so forth there were also Growlers uh
modifications where people took the
smaller paint motor or tire and put it
onto an XR body and with shorter rails
absolutely and you you saw this big
Brewing
um uh uh customizing community that was
not being thought of well by uh the the
future motion Gods the the the one-wheel
uh makers did not really approve of any
of this and um they certainly weren't
designing their boards to make it easy
to do that to be able to respect them
out and at times they actively included
counter modding measures hello everyone
I have something very special for this
podcast's sponsor today we have not only
been graced with turning the podcast
into a lordship we also made a lordship
for Sam no way yeah let me see this yeah
it was through today's sponsor
established titles you can become a
Scottish Lord or lady we purchased a one
square foot plot of land at a private
estate in edelston Scotland my goodness
it's got its own plot Number I see that
an introduce Edition with the historic
customs of Scotland you can now be
referred to as a Lord oh snap dude you
ain't come true can I go up there to get
some poutine I expect Lord to be my
title and then now in accordance with
Scottish tradition you are a lord of the
land oh my goodness it's so official in
fact that you can put it on different
things that have a prefix to the title
you can put Lord Sam Gorski on something
oh dude oh man this has just made life
much more fun this is a really cool way
to help with uh not only just you know a
fun gift for friends and family it helps
with global reforestation efforts as
well they plant a tree for every square
foot of land bot they work with
Charities called one tree planted and
trees for the future
um so that's another cool little thing
it's just in time for the holidays and
the first 200 people to use established
titles.com or cast we'll get a plot
probably within walking distance from
our plot yes which will be heavily
fortified so do not trespass just huge
thanks to them for sponsoring this is a
fun little thing and I also have one
here for lowered court or casts so if
you're interested in getting your own
lordship or lady ship head on over to
establishtitles.com cornercast and
you'll get 10 off dude in this market
damn all right click the link in the
description below back to the podcast
remember the the charge and Ride video
we did so years ago where you and I rode
from my house to the studio you had just
gotten the XR which had just come out I
was still riding on the V1 from 2016 and
there's a mod that I was able to do
which basically allowed me to take a
battery in my backpack go through a
voltage conversion thing and then trick
the one wheel into thinking it was being
charged even though I was writing it
super sketchy you made a video about it
we made a whole video about it future
motion was not pleased
and I guess do you know why they're not
please is there okay we we will get to a
lot of this in this podcast including
how to actually make a vesque including
all the components and stuff this will
be a bit of a podcast here but to answer
your question there are chapter markers
yeah if you want to just jump to the but
it's all good you just keep listening
I've already forgotten your question why
why do you think uh uh future motions
reaction to the customization Market has
been so uh negative I guess well okay
there there's a bunch of sides to the
story one of them is that
it's a bit of a mystery because they
don't really communicate very much about
uh their intents and
sort of feelings about all this stuff
but really what it comes down to is
liability and risk because the moment we
start modifying our boards we introduce
potential failures into the thing which
you know on the surface doesn't seem
like that big of a deal because it's
like well I should be able to do my own
thing and if I mod it and break it
that's my fault great what happens when
you let someone else try it and then
they get hurt whose fault is it then
sure sure well I I would say it's the
person who modified the board's faults
but there's been a lot of court cases
that say no it's future emotions
it's like sue them instead yeah because
no one wants to get sued despite you
know kind of taking on the
responsibility then something happens
you're like oh my last time I checked
there was 70 open lawsuits against
future motion wow I didn't realize it
was full on 70 though I don't know where
you saw that there's a there was a site
where you could actually look up open
lawsuits and there was like 70. I mean
maybe maybe there's not 70 anymore maybe
there's more uh needless to say the
lawsuits do exist yeah and future motion
is dealing with that and they have a
device that if it stops working when
you're cruising along uh you go down
unlike a skateboard or bicycle where
when it dies it becomes a skateboard or
bicycle yeah it's like a helicopter when
it dies
you might die too
and to be fair on a one-wheel going 20
miles an hour if it dies you might die
too like it's possible
every single person in this room has
worn a cast or some form of uh of of
we've all uh sacrificed something to our
boards literally including Christian who
has a broken shoulder at this moment
they have
everyone in here knows how dangerous
they can be so I guess
uh are from future motion standpoint
they're seeing that liability and and
they're they're in a space where they
can only afford so many of these
lawsuits so they're just
I guess putting up uh as many obstacles
in the way uh as they can to prevent you
from modding a board yeah I think I
think it's also important to note uh
that you know future motion
they are not inherently against
modifications what they're against is
the types is the right type of
modification that could potentially
destroy your onewheel or or your life
you know like any once you start messing
with the the motor the battery or the
controller that requires very
specialized skill sets to even try to
modify that's when they're like okay no
not don't do any of that yeah not a big
deal but it's not a big deal but they it
used to be for them like back in the
early days uh you know I I made one of
the first tire change videos on the
internet for the one wheel it certainly
has the most views and you know I I had
talked with future motion about that and
they're like yeah we're constantly
getting people sending their boards in
who are trying to replicate the mods
that you have shown but they're messing
it up and expecting us to fix it under
warranty and it's like
people yeah I don't know
so they've since kind of relaxed that a
little bit I think the community has
grown large enough that they've just
decided to accept it you can now change
out tires on a one-wheel uh without
avoiding your warranty without voting
the warranty they even sell spare tires
as well at race for the rail this year
for the first time ever they allowed
people to ride with different tires on
yeah shout out to John Grace for
apparently being a big guy pushing that
forward and yeah so I think they are
willing to you know be more open to
accessorizing one wheels and that's oh
that's the clear thing they're super
down for accessories not too into
modifications that's the sort of verbal
distinction
I I was trying to clarify so so what
happens when you're a wren white man and
you love your one wheel and the GT comes
out you're like this is nice but I was
hoping for 10 more volts in that battery
pack I was hoping for a different
diameter Tire I was hoping for w shaped
rails I was hoping
for this and that and the other thing
well to be clear I wasn't really
specifically hoping for anything I just
wanted a newer one wheel and they
delivered and I absolutely love the GT
so do I I think it is an incredible
device box a stock uh GT is a it's a
beast it's a beast for those of you that
don't know its writing profile is a
little it's what we would call a little
uh squirrelier the uh uh the the point
of contact between the uh the wheel and
the Earth is smaller so it's a little
more Nimble perhaps uh harder to use in
certain situations but it did basically
double the range double the power and um
added a bunch of fun new features that
were pretty technically I know you're
just I'm just saying casual yes it
didn't technically double the power and
when I got the GT there's a there's a
trail in near Glendale it's in North L.A
kind of between Glendale and Pasadena
right above the highway there we call it
the dragon spine it's a wave-like trail
that basically just goes up and down
like a dragon sleeping on Hills yeah
riding its spine but these are very
steep hills and no one will we've had
has ever been able to climb to the top
of those Hills we get most of the way
then you walk the rest of the way like
the final like 20 feet or whatever then
you ride down the back side and rinse
and repeat on the next Hill uh and so I
was like oh man the GT I want I bet I
can do it I bet I can do it and I'd been
loving the GT like it was so much fun
the power like really being able to just
push it and it just continues to to give
you the power it was really great but
the GT could not handle those Hills
couldn't make it to the top It could
only just slightly do more than the XR
yeah so let's get technical for a second
here because there's gonna be technical
people listening to this podcast and
we're trying to be technical
so one of the things that we're
describing here is torque torque is
basically the power that the wheel the
force that the wheel on the one wheel
slash vasque or whatever can put out so
imagine you're holding onto a stick
that's been stabbed into the wheel and
it tries to spin it's like how much can
a pull that stick away from your hands
that's torque now speed is a little bit
different speed is how fast can you be
going and still have more to give if
you're going 20 miles an hour and you'll
lean on that front of the one wheel to
go faster does it have more to give and
obviously you need some torque to be
able to do that as well but torque
especially low end torque when you're
going slow like you want to crawl over a
bump that comes from current AKA
amperage and speed basically how fast
you can go comes from voltage basically
you need to have a high enough voltage
that the tire that the motor can still
or the battery can still provide Power
when you're going faster
um that's that's a good way of putting
it it is slightly oversimplified it
always still comes down to power yeah
but long story short the reason so the
GT did not have as much torque as I was
expecting mainly because it doesn't have
the ability to put out more amperage it
has a little bit it can do more aperture
than the XR but it can't just completely
open those pipes because the batteries
in these things can dump amps if you
want them to but the controller on the
one wheel GT doesn't let it dump amps it
lets it you know open up a little bit
but it doesn't let it dump amps however
the battery on the GT is a 72 73 volt
battery versus the 63 volt battery in
the XR so that extra 10 volts gives you
a higher range at the high end plus the
ability to actually put more current
through it versus the XR lets you go
faster you have a little more torque at
the low end but you have a lot more
torque at the medium to high ends versus
the XR also partially due to battery
construction it gets kind of complicated
and the reasoning for that is that
there's an inverse relationship between
torque and speed the faster you go the
less torque you have and this is a
self-balancing device that uses torque
to balance you sure So the faster you go
the less ability it has to balance you
and that's where no zives come from
people go really fast and when you're
going pretty fast and you lean forward
just a little too far you don't even
have to lean that far forward the board
is still if if the frame of reference is
like the side of the board and the world
is just flying by but the camera's like
stuck to the person the board still
thinks you're leaning for and is still
trying to get underneath you but when
you're going fast enough it doesn't have
that torque so you end up falling over
but if you're going really slow
especially the the GT you know it's like
it's got a ton of torque you can lean
pretty far forward and it'll still go
and that's created this whole movement
called nose drags where someone it's in
it's on our uh race for the rail video
from a couple years back basically you
drop them you push the nose down and you
just ride it and the motor continues to
try to spin up and and that's a nut
trick
um absolutely terrifying sometimes of
you that do it wow good job good good
object so long story short you know the
GTS come out it it was a step up from
the XR but for many people it's not what
they're looking for because the GT is
very much not modable you can swap a
tire that's about it that's it the GT is
it's a great board they've added a lot
of things to it that are really nice
that I'm looking for like the concave
foot pads I love them oh I love this so
many people are complaining about the
foot pads but I really love them and
that power on the board it's it's a much
stronger board than the XR and if you
know Christian had been riding the GT
instead of the XR he his shoulder may
still be with us today
[Laughter]
um because another thing is that like 20
miles an hour is kind of like the sweet
spot for top speed sure more or less
obviously these things can go faster
because there's no such thing as a break
you can't just artificially stop someone
because these things work by using
physics and the moment you try to put a
break on this thing it's going to throw
you forward I'm always surprised how
many people just cannot grasp that
concept so I guess what I'm trying to
get at is there isn't such thing as a
top speed there's just a top torque yeah
sure and so 20 miles an hour is
generally around the speed where it's
like oh this is this feels pretty fast
yeah I don't really want to go faster
than this yeah and so the GT and the XR
kind of both have the same top speed
quote unquote technically they can do
more the GT is very much so capable of
going faster
than the XR yeah I hit 27 miles an hour
on the GT a couple weeks ago and
it was nuts I was wearing protective
gear and I was very amped and I I do not
try that often but point being 20 miles
an hour on a GT is significantly safer
than 20 miles an hour on an XR because
it's got a lot more Headroom to be able
to give you that power so
it was a smart move on Future motion's
Part in that regard because everyone's
going to be riding in that window and
the power within that window is more
solid yep so the GT is definitely a
safer board however
if you're somebody who has written a lot
of one wheels and you want to mod them
you have very specific things you're
looking for the GT may not scratch that
itch and because future motion is the
only company making one-wheel type
devices
there's nothing else you can turn to and
especially with this winter there's a
there's a lot of I guess anger over a
lack of a right to repair
um aspect to these wheels and you can
send them into future motion to have
them fixed but future motions only in
one spot they don't have repair stations
up anywhere else around the world
for now for now they're working on it
it's not here yet
so you know as far as I'm concerned it's
not here yet yeah once it's here I'll
change my tune but you know if you're
somebody in Europe if you're somebody in
New York and you're using this as your
daily commute and it breaks well you got
to ship your wheel all the way to
California no screw that you want to
just take it to a shop and fix it right
then and there like there's a lot of
need and a lot of desires for things
that people want that aren't necessarily
being scratched by Future motion that
said if you want to try out a one-wheel
future motion is the way to go like if
you have never ridden a one wheel before
and you're listening to be like I want
to build a vesque
buy a one wheel yeah buy like they are
wonderful devices like stock XR got us
around for years and uh not not uh I
mean some complaints uh some broken
bones but uh past that not much yeah if
you can afford it jump up to a GT the
only catch is you got to ship it to
Future motion if it breaks or something
wears out for now
um but hey especially if you're on the
west coast don't hesitate buy a GT like
if you can afford it if you could afford
it like yeah yeah sure buying a used XR
is the best deal you will find yeah you
can get them for anywhere between 800
and 1200 for a used XR not paying sales
tax on it yeah uh if you find one for a
thousand dollars honestly that is a very
good deal yeah be aware though uh a lot
like uh most things with batteries it's
the battery that's going to be the first
thing to give out and that's usually
what leads people to uh you know trying
to get rid of boards for pretty cheap so
just uh thankfully the XR is fixable yes
exactly yeah what is the most expensive
part the battery the battery so so it's
just something to as you're looking at a
used Market be aware that uh the
batteries on those devices are probably
uh probably shot yeah maybe I wouldn't
say probably it really depends a lot of
people will buy a one wheel and they'll
put like maybe 50 or 100 miles on and be
like yeah this isn't really my thing so
you end up with a great deal because
it's like in mint condition sure any
anyone will with like 500 or less miles
is that's a good one wheel yeah sure
sure so I think I want to touch upon one
more thing before we get into the actual
instructions on how to build a vesk so
my if if I were future motion if I if I
was a CEO I would look at vesks as a
blessing because they take a pressure
off of future motion because future
Motion makes a great product they make
they make the device that most people
who want a one-wheeled snowboard-like
device like that's the device buy the
future motion one wheel
um the the vesque audience the people
that want to build their own custom
wheels it's a very small slice of people
that would enjoy riding one wheels and
so I don't think it's going to like
steal any business away from future
motion but more importantly it takes the
pressure off of future motion to have to
worry about hyper specialized machines
it's like somebody wants a really
high-end like Trail Crusher they can
build one with a vesque someone wants a
trick board they can build one with the
vesque someone wants a board that they
can constantly repair and constantly
break because they're crazy lead trying
different things cool you don't have to
worry about future motions lack of
repair centers you can build a vest it
covers the extreme hobbyist uh part of
the the the community and yeah that
that's uh that's great and I mean uh one
of the rides last week uh uh there were
three desks uh um four Riders three
desks and one GT it's not like the GT
didn't keep up we were all uh uh all the
wheels made it through the ride it's
just the the profiles are all different
the way they ride is all different and
uh yeah the the vest kind of uh gives
you a lot of those customizations that
perhaps you're looking for now future
motion does view vesks as competition
they do view it as as something that
they don't want to exist has any company
with a monopoly would want they would
want to not have that around but they
agree they should I'm on you I'm on your
side with that Nico I agree
um I'm not saying that because I like I
like vests I'm saying like if I were the
CEO of future motion a big thank God
vesks exist because now I can focus on
making one wheels and not to worry about
one percent of the audience loudly
complaining all the time that I'm not
making the one wheel that they want yeah
yeah like thank you thank you thank you
take these people away from me so I can
just make one meals and sell them to
everybody else because I was a little I
was a little hesitant about making this
video about vesks and whatnot you know
we've been debating it for literally the
last two or three months and I ended up
kind of eventually coming around to yes
we should do this
partly because of what you're saying but
also partly because it's like
is this really gonna be that much of
like uh this isn't gonna make any Dent
into future motions profits yeah you
know it if anything it's gonna perhaps
slightly help on that front because now
all the people who will be breaking
their boards and sending them in aren't
going to be sending them in anymore
people like I uh in the uh Jimmy Chang
podcast uh Kai was saying that like
a lot of people think that the repairs
are an actual aspect of their business
oh and it's like no it's kind of like a
loss like they take a loss more or less
anytime they have to do repairs even if
it's uh even if they're paying for it's
not under warranty and all that stuff
but like
I mean you do not make money fixing
other people's one Wheels doesn't matter
if you're charging people money for that
like there's there's no volume to be do
like makeup revenue and it's not like
it's you know automobiles where there's
just so many on Market where yeah that
was where I was going with that people
think uh it's a a profitable business
venture repairs because it is in the
automotive industry you know repairing
cars is a whole industry in and of
itself
sure and
yeah and so people kind of just make
that assumption even though it's not
really the case
um so yeah I guess
I eventually came around to it because I
what I don't want to do is I do not want
to harm future motion because I want
them to succeed very badly I want them
to do well and I do not view making a
vest and making a video about how to
make a vesque as being
harmful to them and that was ultimately
why I decided that we should do this
they might disagree with that but I
disagree with their disagreement but who
knows maybe they agree with you yeah I
don't know it's hard to say another
thing about it is that they are very
limited in what they're able to
communicate because of all the liability
and whatnot like even the word choice
that they use for explaining things is
very heavily uh legalized legalized yeah
I mean the company's essentially run by
lawyers which is a bit of a bummer but I
mean you know they got Engineers they
got people who are very passionate about
one-wheeling but at the end of the day
at the end of the day of the semi
lawsuits up you know or at least they
did last time I checked right yeah and
that'll kill your company and that's the
end of one wheels and we don't want one
of those one Wheels to disappear not at
all not at all and yeah and they will if
everybody goes hard against them like
that's just the reality they're not a
huge company sure and so for years I
have been just waiting for the day where
I can just
I don't know that has always scared me
what if they go out of business
I guess I'll have my one will until it
gets so broken I can't repair it anymore
into the future well that that sucks and
no one else is going to be able to buy a
or make a one-wheel build a one-wheel
for whatever reason
um and so I've always been looking
forward to the day where future motion
could go out of business not that I I
really want that to not have I'm just
saying
and I could still continue to enjoy this
thing that I love so much to my core
forever two months ago or two and a half
what occurred that uh uh that made these
wonderful little vests Oh I thought you
were getting at my hand breaking oh no
because that was like two and a half
months ago there is something that
occurred that made this possible which
is
we we at makerspev came out with the
self-contained contained brain for a
vesque
um and he also has kits you can do but
that was our jumping in point Yeah so
basically the vesque movement has been
evolving and growing for the last two
years before that it wasn't really a
thing and I wouldn't even really say the
last two years of it I would it's like a
tiny thing and it's it's hard for people
who are really into the space to
acknowledge this because it's their
whole world they're like everyone just
doing this and it's like yeah all 12 of
you sure yeah
the bar to enter is pretty high right um
You Gotta know a good amount about
electrical engineering Engineering in
general also coding yeah and also be
wealthy enough to uh uh invest but we're
gonna lower that bar on this podcast
right now but yeah so like earlier this
year the firmware which is the code that
controls how the motor responds finally
got to a point where it was actually
kind of like oh this is not bad anymore
okay and I was psyched on you know uh we
got guys like like a Max Mad Max on
YouTube uh you know vesque man surf.o
they're making these really cool videos
about like open yeah
uh vest man
um yeah they're you know they're making
cool videos about this open source one
wheel and they're like it's good now
it's really good and we're like this is
it Nico this is time we bought
everything that you see here is
completely third party with the
exception of the motor again we'll get
to all that and but the main thing was
the controller
um yeah yeah okay there's there's
what am I getting at we jumped in we
built the vesque we got it working and
it was all basically off camera we were
just doing this for ourselves and
it was okay okay
it was just okay the first uh weekend we
went out riding I uh we did the dragon
spine I got on Nico's uh uh vesque and
within maybe 20 seconds all I could
think was the this is gonna kill me this
is just gonna kill me uh if did not feel
stable the that is the nice thing about
the GT it is a very finely tuned piece
of Machinery it feels very solid and
stable I I feel very comfortable like
bombing huge hills with it whereas the
second I got on the vesk as cool as they
are holy crap man oh yeah it was a uh it
made me realize that the relationship
between a rider and the board is all
about trust and the moment you don't
have trust in the board you don't want
to ride like I remember back in the V1
days I had a problem with my foot pad
and it would just randomly turn off yeah
yeah whatever speed and so I'd be going
along and like say 10 miles an hour
I'm not talking about like a nose dive
where you slowly lose power over the
course of a second you know zive it's
not just like a cut off it's like ew it
gives out on you it's like giving up
like the last breath like uh but a cut
out where the power actually goes out is
just like instantly down and and it's so
sudden and jarring that it throws you
and knowing that that could happen at
any time is like I I hated one-wheeling
and the vesque felt like a V1 in terms
of how it rode it has it was a little
quirky it it had like this weird nose
flutter where the nose would like kind
of dip on you and nothing is more
terrifying on a one wheel than the nose
dipping on you it did not build
confidence it did not build trust and
especially getting on the GT and it's
like it's rock solid and you're like oh
this is a premium ride yeah yeah so like
you know we you know nikona we gave it a
solid shot we rode the vesks quite a bit
for like a solid like couple weeks two
or three weeks there before eventually
being like settings tuning levels like
how you just tweak it like tweaking all
over the place oh yeah we tried so many
different settings we tried other
people's tune cards all their settings
and all this stuff and it was just like
at the end of the day I couldn't get a
board that felt good to ride and so I
didn't want to ride it and I would go
back to the GT because I loved the GT
and then
second change that happened was about
like two weeks ago three weeks ago maybe
by the time this podcast comes out
a new firmware update came out for the
vesque and it changed everything yep I
think uh what Mitch I can't remember his
last Mitch yeah I don't know I met him
cool guy he's the guy who helped me uh
change the settings to get it to stand
vertically
um he figured out that basically uh he
was able to apply a filter to just one
axis of the rotation whereas before they
were applying it to all three axes and
it was just making the board feel too
laggy and stuff like that like elastic
elastic kind of dips and that was
causing the nose to do all this weird
stuff yeah and the monster's like wait
what if we just filter one axis the one
that bumps up and down you actually want
to filter and we don't touch the others
and suddenly it's like my board is
perfect now it went from being like this
board is jankier than a V1 to being like
is this the best one wheel what uh what
made it that way what was the uh what
was the winning ticket it was the
confidence in the in in the board you
know it went from
my board was Toby McGuire and then now
it's Toby McGuire if he got bit by a
spider Radioactive
I'll put it this way when you're riding
a GT and you go over a bump the board
stays perfectly flat it is literally
like you are standing on the floor and
you can feel everything moving under you
and you can feel the bumps and stuff but
the board is just Rock Solid it is so
tuned in to the motor and electricity
that the moment Something's Gonna tilt
the board a little bit no it fixes it
and you're just you're riding a rock
solid flat board and when you like start
going faster and faster you're like 15
16 17 miles an hour and you're hitting
bumps and the board doesn't even care
and it's just rock solid and flat you
feel like you can go 20 miles an hour
safely and in fact like the first time
riding the GT I still have my broken
collarbone I hit 19 and a half miles an
hour on the board what's your broken
collarbone yeah remember we were driving
up to see Adam Savage
yeah and we were doing that one like
little dried around on that one smooth
wait he didn't have a wait I was like
three weeks out from my my collarbone
healing and bring broken
yeah it was right at the top of Summer
yep okay and we were on the smooth
streams like I can just go 20 miles an
hour like I because you feel that the
like when you push on the board you feel
it has more to give and it's rock solid
it doesn't dip it doesn't sag and the
vesques were and now they don't now they
have that rock solid feeling that the GT
has you're like I can go 20 miles an
hour and you hit a bump and the board
doesn't care it stays perfectly flat
there's still like it still has some
weird quirks to it we have been
continuing to mess with the settings I
think I finally arrived on a few
settings that I think like make it feel
good now but every now and then there's
still like it depends on like the right
frequency of bumps you hit to confuse
the filters and whatnot and then my nose
will start dipping and it takes a moment
for the nose to come back up that's
that's weird but
it's for the most part Sarah like
Ren would you say the vasque rides
better or worse than the GT
let me guess better in some ways and
worse than others well of course yes I
think I'll say at the end of the day the
GT still rides better it still feels a
little bit more premium this the vesk
feels a little bit more raw uh
but but it can perform but it can
perform yep and there's another thing to
it as well which I've talked with a
bunch of guys who are under the vesque
stuff you know uh Nicole Allman uh Josh
Haley a few other guys from foot life
Fest and you know it's really cool to be
able to kind of discuss these things and
try to figure out what exactly is in the
secret sauce of future emotions like
writing profile because it's pretty
Advanced all this like most people don't
realize that when the board turns it
actually accelerates a little bit and
that's just because if you don't the
nose hits the ground and so it has to
actually accelerate a little bit to lift
that nose anytime you turn and that's
been the case since the V1
and in a vesque you know I think in the
earlier days they didn't really quite
have that tuned in so like it was a
problem and now it's a full-on slider
you can make it really extreme so I can
do these freaking like 1080s just by
standing in one spot by just getting
really up on the side of the the tire
and just start trying to go and it just
spins in place essentially
um
I don't know where I was going with that
just you know tell us about how cool it
is well here I think this is a perfect
time for us to be like all right ladies
and gentlemen the tutorial is going to
begin now we're going to open this
tutorial with some thanks I want to
thank surf dotto for all the work he's
done I want to thank we for all the work
he's done as well Mitch for making one
Wheels great
um sorry for making vests uh ride really
smoothly
um Mad Max for all the work he's done
with making YouTube videos and kind of
introducing people to this nice guy nice
guy does that mean like honest honest is
making cool videos but uh Max was the
dude actually like I don't know making
the types of videos that got casual
one-wheel Riders like hyped he got me
hyped and and that was kind of like he
was the guy who literally pushed both of
us over the edge to jump into this yep
and also a quick little shout to uh
float wheel flow glider chai battery
like they're making the piece of
Engineers to make this for engineers
yeah and we'll get into all components
here in a moment that float wheel not
float wheel I don't no that's the wrong
name yeah I mean sure thank him whatever
but I misspoke
there's so many different like one-wheel
companies out there now like like I'm
wearing a shirt a float gang based out
of Florida I mean it's a bunch of Crews
you know it's like they'll make podcasts
uh flow gang uh you know they'll make
t-shirts and when they start getting
bigger they actually start making big
accessories the biggest company I think
would probably be either the float life
or craft and ride yeah sure and
they make excess that like literally
their entire business
is piggybacking off of this one device
from a company and making great products
I mean the bang for your buck is
incredible through all uh yeah I adore
craft and ride uh Nick and Mike those
guys are super awesome they're they're
the kind of guys you want to run a
company and yeah they care about
customer service they make great
products and they also uh distribute a
lot of other accessories that other
people make and so it's kind of like car
like crafting.com I think it's kind of
like a One-Stop shop for pretty much any
one-wheel accessory commercially invest
tutorial best tutorial right yeah sorry
okay so point being what uh what is a a
one meal like device made out of REM
okay so a one wheeled device if you were
to try to simplify this down to the most
simple components you have a motor a
brain and a power source and some sort
of vessel that holds all of it together
and a one-wheel skeleton yeah and so
like yeah you have the motor and tire
you have the front foot pad and the back
foot pad which has a volume inside of it
that you can put other things in
um if we're parting out aboard the the
main I guess architecture revolves
around the rails and we are using these
rails from the fungeneers fungineers.com
I think might be their website uh
they're I think they might be mostly on
Facebook they uh this is their first
rail setup I believe uh but float life
has been making rails for a long time a
bunch of
a variety of those tires a bunch of
different options for tires as well as
foot pads and even bumpers like four
different companies are making bumpers
now yep and the bumpers are the the
element that's on the bottom that
prevents your uh your your brain and
your battery from being damaged these
are a special edition Corridor Digital
bumpers from the float life which I
believe now are just up as regular
bumpers I mean probably yeah just black
and yellow bumpers yep yeah so so if
you're going to build a vesque you need
a motor and a tire
you're going to need a brain and some
sort of compartment to hold the brain
you're going to need a battery and some
sort of compartment to hold the battery
you're going to need rails which are the
two metal pieces on the side of the one
wheel slash vesque that hold this all
together
you're going to need foot pads so you
can stand on the board and in particular
the front foot pad needs a sensor to
turn the board on and off and that's if
you want to model it after a one wheel
the great thing about vesque is suddenly
you can make those constraints go away
yeah but let's just assume we're going
to do it the way we did it yeah also
you're gonna need a charger for the
battery don't forget when you get a
battery you also need to have a charger
for it sure okay so step one
what do you do in the Box buy a used XR
step one yeah if you're trying to start
out and building a vest your very first
ever event and is that anything no no
use deck so if you're starting out just
yeah get into one Wheeling yeah get into
one Wheeling start with one wheels so
yeah I guess once you're once your XR is
broken and it can it be does it have to
be a specific XR like people are doing
with pine speed uh people are doing with
like V ones and pluses you don't need
any one wheel you don't need any one
wheel or future motion Parts also but
we're just going to approach this from a
simple approachable direction right so
the vast majority of people who would be
interested in getting the vesque there's
probably two groups one you live
overseas and getting one wheels are kind
of difficult for you and
you know especially the concept of
having to have it repaired and shipping
it across the ocean that sucks and you I
can totally see that being an interest
of for you to get into one Wheeling by
just jumping into the deep end by
building a desk I wouldn't recommend it
but I get it secondly it's going to be
people who already have a one wheel that
maybe have broken it or they want to try
this out and whatnot you know all of
that uh there's various reasons maybe
they they want a different battery maybe
they don't want the BMS the battery
management system which is a whole
computer chip inside of the battery
compartment that is fragile uh to put it
one way and there it often breaks after
a certain amount of Miles uh your your
BMS is uh uh will probably burn out yeah
so if you have a an XR used broken
doesn't matter you effectively have all
the parts you need to make a vesque
outside of a brain and arguably a
battery you could use the stock battery
but if you're gonna make a mask most
let's be real most people are going to
use the stock battery because there
aren't any other options right now there
are there are a couple when we get to
the battery statement we'll talk about
that so
so starting out let's talk about the
non-electronic components you're going
to need a set of rails I recommend you
check out the rails from float life
or the rails from Engineers the Thunder
rails start with those or if you have a
used XR you can just simply use the
rails from your XR get whatever you'd
like but check out those resources you
could probably also go on Facebook
Marketplace and just search one-wheel
Parts some people like will literally
have their one wheel and they will break
it down into their components and sell
those components individually because
there's a whole Marketplace for the
controller of a one wheel for the BMS of
a one wheel because you can't buy them
on their own in order for you to get
your hands on one someone else had to
disassemble it one wheel yeah sure it's
like heart transplants you know it's
like you can't just buy a heart someone
has to die
so continuing down the slide of the
non-electronics part of this so you have
your rails you're going to need
compartments to store your brain and
your battery so we'll get to the brain
in a second that the compartment's kind
of built into that but the battery once
again you can use the battery
compartment from an XR you could also 3D
print one or you can buy the torque box
which is from I think it's Badger wheel
I don't know if they have a different
company name but the torque box is a
specific battery compartment that fits
in a XR style frame
and it's a little extra big so you can
fit a little bit of an extra big battery
inside of it you will however need a
specific bumper that fits the torque box
because it's bigger than an XR battery
compartment you can use an XRS battery
compartment as well if you want
especially if you're using a stock
battery sure but if you're going to use
like a chai uh again all these
modifications are probably going to
require you to bust out a Dremel okay
we'll get to that in the batteries yeah
sure because that's going to be a whole
chapter that's definitely like the
biggest challenge of this but so far in
our non-electronic pieces we've got
rails we have the compartment that holds
the battery and that could be the one
that comes with an XR or can be the
torque box or it can be a 3D printed
thing now we need to talk about bumpers
you can get these amazing bumpers from
the float life or if you have the torque
box like I was talking about the thing
that holds the battery you'll need a
special bumper for that and I think that
I can't remember the name of that type
of bumper is it the it's like the torque
bumper or something like that isn't it
made by uh Badger wheel it's made in
association at the very okay yeah so
final little bit here is the foot pads
and that kind of transitions us to
Tronics rear foot pad I recommend the
Kush pad it's lovely because wide is my
favorite you get it from Craft and ride
nothing electronic about it it's just
rubber
in the front foot pad however needs to
have a sensor in it so you can buy you
can buy foot pads that have the sensor
um I don't actually know where I have
any recommendations but we'll probably
in the description below however
you just go on future motion
onewheel.com and you can buy their foot
pads sure now
frustratingly though you can't buy just
the front foot pad yes you're gonna get
the back you're gonna get a set and I'm
not even sure you can still buy XR foot
pads oh that's right I don't know if you
can because they discontinued the XR wow
yeah you could for a while I have a
feeling it's still up I could be wrong
you know because I I saw they still had
V1 uh some V1 Parts on there so yeah I'd
be surprised if I mean I don't know
that's that's what I'm doing I'm running
an XR footpad on the front of my way
same yep it's okay so basically got your
non-mechanical your non-electronic
things out of the way and by the way we
just constructed like half of our one
wheel or sorry our vesque I told you
it'd be confusing look at how easy that
was halfway there we're halfway there
okay let's get into the first important
thing the brain here's what everybody
should do head on over to
makerspev.com I believe.com I
believe.com I believe that now if you're
lucky
we has his uh fully assembled units for
sale at the time that you hear this
podcast realistically he won't
realistically he'll be sold out because
they are amazing and he's just like it's
like two dudes making them sure um but
hey welcome to the world of Open Source
DIY right hop onto the Facebook one meal
group the one-wheel vest Builders Group
or pv.dv yeah the Forum pev Dev
and if they aren't available ask if
they'll be available or wait or check
the site a few weeks he's actively
working on them like they're coming out
these shipping them all the time so but
it's like literally just two or three
guys yeah it's they're just dudes so
like you want one just go talk to them
if they're not available just just or
just you know be patient in a few weeks
it'll pop up you know so what what he's
making though so the desk is literally a
computer chip yep it's a just a big it's
like an articulated uh silicon board
with a bunch of like capacitors mosfets
inductors all that stuff that controls a
motor
that's what the vesque is but you can't
just like take that and like tape it to
your one wheel and expect it to work so
what has had to come out around that is
an entire enclosure for it and an
enclosure that has all the correct
Dimensions to fit one-wheel rails the XR
one will raise it's really like the
screw points yeah exactly and so what's
inside of that is essentially just that
vesk the the chip with a big heat sink
and stuff like that various plugs and
stuff for the the charger the power
button here yep there's a power button
on one side which is red look at that
it's pretty sick pretty sick
um
yeah and and so I guess the angle that
makers pev has taken is by taking taking
like the the flow glider kit essentially
and combining it with uh their own
design for the the actual 3D printed
enclosure they did tons of testing to
figure out what won't break uh what is
watertight enough you know various types
of plastic you know ABS pet G pla Etc
all those things and they I think
they've settled on a design that will
work continue uh continue to work going
forward and the big thing about the kit
though is that the plugs and connectors
are all compatible with regular
one-wheel XRS yep that's the big thing
so the battery plug is the same you can
use your regular battery plug it in the
one-wheel motor has a weird freaking
automotive type plug on it you can plug
it into the the vesk yep you basically
can swap the brain and you're almost
good to go like if you have an XR you
take out the future motion brain and you
put in your vest brain from makerspev
you plug everything in and you're
basically good to go I guess that's
people almost so let's say you have a
one-wheel XR and your board broke
somehow and you have to send it in to
get repaired whether the BMS was uh
broken or the controller was broken that
could be upwards of five or six hundred
dollars to fix sure assuming it's out of
warranty if it's under warranty and
you're not if it's the next hour it's
probably not in water warranty anymore
I mean yeah I don't know
point being
you know that's several hundred dollars
worth of repairs just to get it back to
where you were or you can spend I think
they're like 400 700 bucks for for the
fully self-assembled box for the the
letterbox okay for the best
um which is a s that I mean that's not
cheap I understand that it's certainly
not cheap but it opens up a lot of doors
and a lot of possibilities and you can
another thing is that the vesk actually
does unlock more power from the motor
yeah so remember at the beginning of
this conversation I was talking about
torque and now torque especially low end
comes from current and future motions uh
brain has a smaller pipe than the vesk
the the pipe on the vesque is much much
bigger to the point where you can
basically pull all the amps that your
battery can give and it's more about how
many amps can the motor handle and the
vest is like I'll give the motor as much
amps as it wants and the motor is like I
can't handle anymore so you're kind of
like sacrificing a little bit of range
and uh um also durability because that's
another name of the game for future
motion because they are selling devices
that need to last for years and
thousands of miles and so they
artificially limit the power going to
the motor like the the braking current
the actual like current that goes to it
is limited I don't know what the actual
amperage is maybe 30 or 35 amps I'm not
exactly sure
um
it doesn't matter point being is that it
doesn't matter they are limiting it in a
way that you can't
throw too much power into the device
that will cause the components to
eventually wear out faster sure yeah and
that's not a problem with the vesk okay
so let's say it technically is a problem
that's why I'm getting started it is
technically it's definitely a problem
just be easy on your equipment yeah uh
so let's say you go to make SPD and you
go to buy that flow glider box and it's
just not there right the holy
self-assembled kit it's just not
available you really want to jump in
well guess what it's actually still
really easy to jump in Jan hit me so
they have a full kit they saw makerspv
it's all the parts for the vest
including the vest the wires the
connectors
um you specifically want the non-heat
sync version because then you're going
to head over to flowglider.com you're
going to get the lid for the Box you're
going to get the lid that has the mount
for the vesque because that metal lid on
the box is going to act as your heat
sink okay okay and there is a tutorial
video that shows how to take all the
pieces from makers pev and you're going
to 3D print the box or you can buy one I
recommend checking out lit timber for 3D
printed boxes uh you can get
specifically the lid mount box and you
can just get specifically the lid Mount
lid from flow glider so once again it's
the kit for Maker's pev the non-heat
sync vesque Kit full DIY kit comes with
all the cables you're gonna get the box
for the brain from lit Timber or print
it yourself
um or there's other people that offer
too you can easily hop onto the Facebook
group and ask sure but lit Timber has
like carbon fiber prints I got
everything and then you're going to get
the lid Mount lid from flow glider
you're going to assemble it yourself it
takes like 15 minutes it's not that hard
you plug in a couple cables you put a
couple things in the spots and you're
done there's like maybe it's going to
take longer than 15. there's actually a
video of it it's very straightforward
now with the lid Mount it's actually
very very straightforward it's literally
about as simple as plugging a GPU and
some RAM and like connecting your power
supply to like PC parts if you've ever
opened up a PC and like swap the GPU you
can build a brain for your for your one
wheel so it's for sure you're still
probably assuming a lot at the second
time through it'll be 15 minutes yeah
it's important to know if you are at all
hesitant around Electronics this is not
the project for you
yes or it is and you're going to get
less hesitant as you go I mean yeah
there's a bunch of people that are very
helpful but once again you watch this
video of building a vesque brain in the
full bladder box it's it's very
straightforward it is like an
intermediate Lego build like it's not
that complicated just follow the
instructions have you ever built a death
star you could build a vet
so you got your 3D printed box you got
your electronics inside of it you got
your lid on top and now you have your
self-enclosed brain ready to go that's
really all there is to it makers pev
flow glider for the lids and either
print your own box find something to
print it for you or buy one from like
lit Timber or something like that
there's another option there's another
option from fungineers so we have this
uh if you buy a set of rails or if you
buy their super flux motor actually I
don't know about that one don't quote me
on that but at the very least if you
bought their Thunder rails which we have
here it comes with the metal lid for
both the front and the back compartment
enclosure and files STL files that you
can 3D print for the controller or the
battery box yeah which happens to be
literally what you're buying if you go
to LIT Timber you're buying a 3D printed
version of that STL file yeah and you
can also just I mean you can take the
STL file there are tons of services out
there that will print it for you yeah
okay yeah so lots of ways to get your
box printed uh but at the end of the day
you're going to get your metal lid lid
Mount style for the vesque from flow
glider and you're going to get the kit
for makers pev or if you're lucky slash
willing to drop a little extra money get
the fully self-assembled kit for
makerspev if it's available
boom your brain's taken care of
Next Step
there is I mean
the the future motion battery one of the
anti-modification things they've tried
doing is literally just taking the plug
and putting it on backwards
and that kind of sucks if you know about
it it's not a problem so it's not really
a very effective thing in my mind
they're just creating problems where
people accidentally destroy stuff but
the future motion battery is the
negative is positive and the positive is
negative yeah and so the the makers pev
controller
it doesn't have it reversed we told me
that he refused to put in a reversed
plug good for him built into it he's
like no I can't yeah and so if you want
to use your your stock uh battery with
the the makerspev
um kit he's got a little plug inverter
that basically just reverses it and you
just you plug it in yep okay so you got
your brain and like I said there's a
bunch of instructions for the details
like you plug this here you plug this
here you put this here you attach this
here once again it's very
straightforward you watch the video of
the guy so I'm gonna be like oh this is
very straightforward
um but you got your brain and you know
what you slip it on those rails screw it
in boom you're done right
or the brain the brain now we have to
deal with the battery and then we have
to deal with connecting everything right
so next step is the battery things get a
little more complicated here
a little a lot more all right Ren and I
were lucky enough to get cbsco batteries
from chai Battery Systems before they
discontinued them and he's a CSO CBS CBC
cbcso
um and chai battery if you're listening
please we need another battery that has
a self-contained BMS it doesn't have to
be 84 volts it could be 80 volts it
could be 76 volts it doesn't matter but
please the DIY that's the context that
that supports it needs another battery
with a built-in BMS listen to us listen
hear our words okay so there is there
aren't really there haven't been many
options for one wheel batteries if your
battery dies you have to send it in
they'll put a new one and then you can
carry on your way then this company
based out of Chicago called chai Battery
Systems sprung up making replacement
batteries that you can just swap out if
you know how to like take out screws
it's like it wasn't actually that hard
and they're like but there is a little
bit more space in here what if we took
out the little spacers between the
batteries and packed in
double the batteries and that was where
my favorite battery came out which is
called the cbxr it was a battery that
was meant for the onewheel XR and it
essentially went twice as far I was
easily able to get like over 20 miles of
range on a cbxr even though they would
advertise like 25 to 30 miles I was like
no yeah yeah I mean not the pace that we
read well in that yeah exactly and so
they've they've got replacement
batteries for the pints uh for the Plus
for the XR and earlier this year they
came out with a new battery that
specifically meant for vesque conversion
kits and it was specifically designed to
fit within the enclosure for the
onewheel XR and it was a 20 cell battery
compared to the XR which was a 15 cell
battery what does that mean it means you
have 15 individual little lithium ion
cells in series to add up to a certain
voltage and the batteries we have are 20
cells so there's an additional five
cells in series to increase that voltage
also there's like two Series in parallel
it doesn't matter point being it's a
more powerful battery and it's
incompatible with any one wheel
again this is not a one wheel and so
we thought this is it this is this is
what we've been wanting we want because
the the stock battery pack on a vest was
already outperforming a GT and a GT has
has higher voltage uh Mad Max showed
that in his videos and so
we're like oh man bigger battery pack we
got it it's really cool 84 volts is
amazing here's the maximum the best can
take by the way it's 84 volts
and
promptly couldn't fit it in the battery
enclosure
it could not fit and so
and they're like yeah no you just gotta
like cut away some of the plastic
material
bruh it's not we spent an entire day
basically just dremeling out the inside
of the battery enclosure we're just like
full on like all right all these little
plastic bits they're gone and we're
shaving it down like oh sure of course
shooting into cbxr uh cbxr was a hard
fit too yeah this is significantly
harder wow yeah and to the point where
like you get it all in there it packs in
you put the metal lid on and there's
like a four or five millimeter gap
between the bottom of the enclosure and
the metal lid that sits on top of it and
so you have to like take clamps to clamp
it down just so you can get the screw in
far enough to catch and then you can
squeeze that corner and then go to the
other side put that corner in and go
around the perimeter and then slowly
just tighten them all down until the the
metal plate literally pulls that down
nothing gets squeezed out of place and
so that has been problematic you know
that is that you know you put that much
pressure on on the batteries the battery
cells themselves are actually pretty
dang strong but the connections between
the batteries are not and so the cbcso
has these little has these little I call
them bunny ears it's literally uh four
extra cells two two pairs of two cells
that stick out and then out like that
and they basically they sit up and they
sit flush at the end of the Rails you
see how there's like this little uh like
angle here there's a gap here and they
put those cells there but they just
barely fit they just and saying that
they just barely fit also feels a little
like
um it's a generous term
it was significant effort for us to get
those batteries it took about four hours
five hours for us but we did get them in
yes and the board did work after that
and it continues to work yes now it's
worth mentioning another beautiful thing
about the cbcso is it has a built-in
battery management system so what is a
BMS what is a battery management system
well as Wren pointed out here you don't
have one battery a battery's actually
like 20 batteries in our cases 40
technically 40. so what happens when one
battery in one individual cell is a
little bit imbalanced versus the other
cells and it's charged at a different
rate well you don't really have any way
to address that problem unless you have
a battery management system sure or for
example what happens if the thing
overheats what happens if the current
draw is going too fast you need to like
cut it off what happens if it gets too
low so there's all these things you have
around just the raw batteries to protect
them to modulate them to let you charge
them safely to let you discharge them
safely and that's all involved in your
battery management system
it is possible to put a battery in your
vesk without a BMS and just write it it
is completely possible but at some point
you're gonna have to balance the cells
in that battery so having a BMS is great
now if you use a stock battery you can
also use the stock future motion battery
management system and you can still use
that with your vest there's instructions
online to figure out how you do that you
basically just have to connect a certain
wire or solder a certain wire and then
you can read the info and if it's one of
the newer models you technically need to
add a little chip in line there once
again it sounds complicated it's really
not it's just taking one wire soldering
it to the chip taking another wire
soldering it to the chip I've done it
yeah it's very do my old bms's yeah
because future motion's newer XRS two
years ago uh started coming out with
bms's that were tied to the controller
this is part of what makes it very
frustrating for people like me because
of the whole you know people talk about
the right to repair stuff with future
motion is because they pull stuff like
that where it's like my battery is dead
but I can't change it out because the
the battery management system which is
there to protect the battery
will literally make it incompatible with
any other controller except the one that
came with it from the factory and so
people eventually figured out how to
bypass the checks that they put in place
and so you solder in this chip and yeah
whatever yep that's how you do it um
that's if you want to use the future
motion battery but long story short
having a battery with a built-in BMS is
a godsend and it's a great way to go
unfortunately the cbcso is not available
however
indiespeedcontrol.com
they make a vest battery it's a 20 cell
battery 84 volts has a BMS built into it
and it does not fit the stock
yeah it does not enclosure the stock
enclosure you know what that's fine
because frankly neither did the CPC
the uh the one from Indie speed control
or India speed was it indeed uh yeah it
needs to be controlled there's Tech this
fits the torque box gotcha okay yeah and
just another quick shout out to Chai
Battery Systems so yes I love this
company for the record they have the
torque pack but it's sold out hopefully
it comes back in stock
um yeah so they they the cbcs sorry the
cbxr
so many freaking acronyms they also have
What's called the board bank which is
essentially just a battery pack and a
little enclosure with a wire sticking
out of it so when your one wheel gets
slow and you're not near a wall outlet
you take this out of your backpack plug
it in it's incredible I miss using it I
love it but I don't I don't ride XRS
anymore so I can't use it and you cannot
use one on a GT either because of the
proprietary plug that they use has a
special little computer chip inside the
plug that communicates with a special
signal to the controller and if you're
not getting that exact signal you can't
charge the board on a GT I'm getting
okay so chai Battery Systems uh they
make these batteries and the I think
they've always been pretty good quality
but the cbcso came out and people
started having quality control issues to
the point that Tri batteries they they
delisted the product from their page
like you cannot buy one right now it's
not that it's sold out they literally
discontinued it yeah but once again try
try I know I know suron electric dirt
bikes are sick and it is awesome that
you guys are making batteries then
please please usk vesque boys we need a
battery solution for our one Wheels
granted there's other options you can
ask people on Facebook to build a
battery for you you know this is
indiespeed control.com guy that you know
I just call up here who knows if their
batteries are cool I hope they are um
talk about them here on the podcast but
at the end of the day chai Battery
Systems has been our go-to for years I
definitely trust them I think trying to
pack 84 volts 20 cells into a one wheel
a standard like XR enclosure it's just
too much yeah
um dropping it down to 19 or 18 cells I
think 18 would be the sweet spot because
that would allow you to get rid to those
bunny ears yep and 18s is the same
voltage as the GT yep and then they also
like they have the torque box from
Badger wheel and theoretically chai
Battery Systems makes a battery
specifically for the torque box it is
sold out right now I don't know if it's
coming back but once again chai even if
it's just for the torque box you're just
working together you work with somebody
else please please please help us find a
solution for one wheel uh sorry vesque
batteries but in the meantime do not be
discouraged if you're trying to build a
vesque check out these other services go
to the Facebook group you can find
options like they're out there
um at the end of the day though you
really want to try to find a battery
with a built-in BMS you're going to need
a cable to run from that battery to your
controller on the other end of your vesk
I don't know I consider stuff like
cables and connectors and all that stuff
to be trivial well there's all this one
of them isn't communicating properly
in the sense you can get them yes well
Maker's pev has the one cable you're
looking for it is a battery cable that's
all you need turns out you only need one
cable it's the cable that goes from the
battery to the controller because the
motor comes in the stone cable okay so
that's it turns out I only need to talk
about one cable makers pev offers it but
yes so we've talked about the brain you
build the brain we talked about the
battery I throw an adoption where you
can buy a battery you can use a stock
battery from an XR you could probably
even use the cbxr you're gonna need to
find a battery management system
but there are solutions out there also
it you do not have to have a BMS in your
board it is there to protect you you are
running a risk without it but the
we talk about like the cells balancing
Good batteries they don't just go out of
balance it's one of those things
batteries start going out of balance
when you do a lot of uh repeated charges
so like a full cycle is when like they
start off at full battery and they drain
down to zero and then they come back up
this is never a problem on our phones
and laptops because there's only one
cell it's just one battery cell and
that's it but when you have a lot of
cells working together when they they
have different internal resistances and
so their charge rate is inherently going
to be slightly different and so charging
up to full and then discharging back
down each cell's rate of discharge and
charging is going to be slightly
different so that it's not a matter of
time it's a matter of Cycles 100 Cycles
to 300 Cycles which is a lot of charges
they'll start being really out of
balance and the point of a battery
management system is that it charges it
up to full and then it slowly discharges
each of the cells down until they all
match up and then it charges everything
back up to full again that is in very
important thing and that's been a
problem on one wheel like stars in the
past like oh my board is dying at like
20 or 30 percent it's because one of the
cells is weaker and when that one hits
the bottom it doesn't matter what the
charge of all the other battery cells
are your board is dead yeah done out of
battery so every cell every battery cell
4.2 volts on a cell is full and 3.2
volts is basically empty sure getting
down below 3.2 volts into 3.1 3.0 volts
per cell and they start to dip pretty
quick as you get down there you can
start to damage the battery yeah so
that's why you have an empty point on
batteries because that's the point where
you're not damaging the battery yet so
as you are using your board and you are
looking at your battery because you're
going to have raw control over
everything you want to make sure you're
looking at your battery cells and making
sure they're not dipping below 3.2 volts
as you ride
yeah now again uh the controller can do
that for you
instead of the battery management system
it's just not doing it on an individual
cell basis that would only protect you
from over charging and over discharging
so like if you add up the voltage of all
the cells that's the total voltage of
the battery pack and the controller sees
that voltage and so once it gets down to
3.2 times 15 or times 20 or however many
cells you have in your pack once it hits
that Mark the controller is like okay
your battery is now at like zero percent
we're going to safely and slowly
encourage you to get off the board Yeah
by slowly changing like the the default
angle to be tail down as opposed to just
completely shutting off on you sure sure
and that protects the battery so an easy
way to measure your battery if you don't
have access to anything or you just have
the basic voltage is you take the number
of cells let's say in this case when I
have batteries with 20 cells in them
well 20 cells times 4.2 is 4.2 Volts for
each cell at full equals 84. 84 volts
there you go so when your board's at 84
you're basically full so how about 3.2
well 3.2 volts per cell times 20 is 64
volts so as we're riding along I can
look at my phone and Grant it's not
perfect because voltage does change
depending on how much you're pulling
from the battery sure but if I'm sitting
at
74 volts I'm about halfway gone with my
battery sure not exact but close enough
right so that's how you generally use
voltage to measure your capacity and
when you're doing a DIY project like
this you're probably going to be using
voltage to measure your capacity
yeah it's it's like if you're going to
get into this like reading voltage is is
something you're going to have to learn
like understanding oh okay at this
voltage I'm at around 70 battery oh at
this voltage I'm like around 30 battery
though there are gauges that kind of
show you but and some Guides Online I've
used uh in the past when I had a cbxr uh
XR yeah yeah so you got a source of
Battery Solution and it needs to have a
BMS hopefully chai hears our please but
in the meantime there's other options
other Solutions once again head over to
pv.dev or the Facebook vesque Builders
Group uh one wheel of desk Builders
Group and ask for Solutions there if you
can't find any I think most people
watching this if they're going to be
getting into it will be using their
stock XR battery pack and that's totally
fine yep 100 totally fine we're going to
get an amazing torque out of it we were
riding the other night with uh Brendan
uh uh floaty as he's called floaty McFly
he won race to the rail in 2020. he's
been around for years world champion one
wheel already so yeah just a just a
stand-up guy just yeah dude yeah and
yeah so he was on his desk and keeping
up with us on a stock XR battery pack
yep now granted he runs out of battery
much faster than we do but he's hitting
the same drops he's hitting climbs yeah
and having no trouble uh uh keep it well
leading the pack yeah no trouble yeah so
leading the pack sometimes so all of you
out there with XRS who are thinking
about fescing them you will see a
performance increase even with the same
battery you already have you know we we
haven't mentioned the the one downside
or the draw there's a drawback here that
uh uh is pretty considerable to to me uh
where did your lights go oh my God
you're right I was out there on those
buttery trails and you know ton of light
coming off of my board but then I would
look back at just darkness uh headlamps
and flashlights
where I again remind everyone that this
is so early days for the open source
like one wheel movement you know like
it's been two years all of the really
exciting stuff has been this year but
even then it's like there's only a small
handful of people like I literally met
the dude who designed the board for the
vesque and the guy who wrote the code
for the vesque at float life Fest this
year it's like two people granted there
are a bunch of like a small handful of
other people contributing to the project
primarily surf.o uh and
yeah it's not many people working on
this and so they haven't been able to
get around to the lights yet so it's a
small thing right yeah if you want to
have lights you have to buy an extra
component that can talk to the board and
power it and all that stuff and then you
get the LEDs in there and so like if you
look carefully I don't know if you can
see this on the yeah about right here so
there is
a little panel where the lights go about
right here
there are no lights here that's just a
plastic wall
yep so so needless to say at this point
in the tutorial we've talked about
building the brain and where you can go
to build the brain the things you can
use to watch and how to do it we've
talked about the battery ways you can
Source a battery
remember using your stock battery
the positive negative wires will flip
the red wire is the negative the black
wire is the positive on the future
motion battery so when you plug that
into your vest brain you'll need to have
a little adapter it's going to flip it
over again and there's nothing
preventing you from just plugging it in
and killing your vest actually I'm
pretty sure the Vex won't die really
okay that's good to know yeah I
apprecially have a pretty solid built-in
Uh current protection now with this but
regardless it's like it's super
dangerous versus the polarity on a plug
for a battery and plug it into anything
it would instantly fry whatever it is
you plug it into and potentially short
circuit your own battery and cause it
cause Explorer yeah sure so don't do
that remember if using a stock battery
it's flipped just follow instructions
read everything twice
um okay so now you have your battery and
you have your brain simple enough it's
in a box whether it's the torque pack or
you're using a standard XR box
screw it to your rails all right you got
your rails you got your battery on the
back you got your brain on the front
grab your motor okay where do you get a
motor from as of this point there's only
two options either an XR motor a
hypercore which there's a lot of hyper
core Motors floating there's a lot you
can probably you can Source One without
too much effort it's not going to be
cheap I mean you're probably looking at
like 300 or more for a motor yep
probably four or five hundred actually
probably more like four or five but you
can get a super Flex motor from
fungineers the same people that make the
Thunder rails for about 350 bucks well
that was how much we got it for in the
first I looked at the the price on the
side I think it still sucks it's gonna
say that that price I don't know but
it's still sub 400 bucks as of now
either way that is a is a motor that's
technically more powerful and faster
than the uh hypercore motor that said
the hyper core motor is exceptional it's
great wonderful motor yep so you are
going to be fine with the hyper core
mode tell whatever they did to the GT
the motor on the GT is in my opinion a
downgrade from the XR everything else
about the GT is incredible but the motor
which is weird because the motor is kind
of technically the same motor as the XR
the stator is the same but the Hub which
is the thing that actually spins and has
the tire on it basically has a lining of
magnets surrounding it and those magnets
interact with the copper coils of the
stator you know you have like
the electricity going into the stator
that creates these uh electrical
currents that create magnetism that
pushes on the magnets of the Hub in a
very very precise synchronized way that
causes it to spin now those magnets are
like a few like maybe three or four
newton meters more powerful on the GT
than the XR but they're also not held in
as well and as a result of that maybe as
a result of that don't quote me on that
the heat transfer of the heat generated
in those magnets isn't able to get out
as well and so you end up with a lot of
efficiency losses on the GT motor on top
of the whole in my opinion a debacle
between the axle block and the rail
there's a heat pattern there's a heating
issue for sure the GT is not able to get
rid of heat and it overheats it's very
frustrating for me
we had an interesting uh situation on
top of a mountain where Ren's board was
almost boiling it was almost 200 degrees
yeah and it's making this weird sound
and we're like uh oh we're on top of a
mountain and there's no way to get down
because Ren's GT is dead
lifting it up out the ground he's like
put his fingers in the pad he's tilting
it forwards and he's going
it made the world's most awful grinding
sound I threw out the idea
make it go backwards maybe that'll fix
it
and it did
I don't know what happened today I don't
know what happened like near I honestly
the only thing so this is a hypothesis I
I it's pure speculation I think what
happened because it did get hotter than
it should have been on for it should
have turned off by that point I saw it
at like 187 degrees Fahrenheit I wish I
got a screen cap I didn't and at one
point are we like cooking the board
what's up healthy so I thought like this
what happens when it gets too hot so
when when the motor gets too hot the
magnets which are just permanent magnets
like the ones you stick to your fridge
they demagnetize and they lose their
ability to react to the stator pushing
out making it move they become dumb
chunks of metal yeah and and then that
creates a compounding problem where the
circuitry of the board is expecting a
certain response from the magnets and
when it's not getting that response it
it thinks it's in a certain orientation
and it's not and you end up with like I
said a compounding effect of it just not
working uh that temperature at which
magnets demagnetizes around 210 degrees
uh Fahrenheit
right something like that something
around it's around that point either way
you were tickling it I was tickling it
for sure and so what I think happened is
that I think the glue became dislodged
because the GT magnets again are only
glued on the tips not along the entire
length of the magnet like they are in
the XR and so they're not held in as
well and I thought maybe it had just
slightly come out
from the thing and was now grinding
along the stator oh wow as it's spinning
around and when I reversed it it just
went back in somehow and re I don't know
I don't know I don't know I'm fairly
certain I didn't have something stuck in
the bumper or the foot pad you know how
sometimes you get like a leash yeah
anything stuck remember you tried to
write it it was constantly giving you
warning beeps yeah it was super bizarre
needless to say I'm a technological
Savant and a whisper of computers I'd
like to remind everybody that when we
filmed son of a dungeon the computer
wouldn't turn on and I went turn it
sideways and I fixed it
so you know when it comes to dumb
suggestions that fix things you're like
The Fawns with a jukebox so you just
know yep ah let me hit it right there
boom I'm gone so when it comes to brings
back to the vest for a second you will
need to manage your own heat on the vesk
it's not gonna overheat as quick as the
GT but it won't also necessarily tell
you when you're getting too hot you'll
have to be aware of what just like you
know if you're making a race car you
also be aware of when are you pushing it
too far and what what's the range yeah
basically once you start popping just
like a CPU once you start popping 70
degrees Celsius you should probably get
off the board sure realistically yeah
once you start popping 60 chill out if
you're starting to pop 70 stop riding
yeah well I yeah I mean the thermal
management is better with these rails
because the rails essentially act as a
heat sink all the mode all the heat from
the motor goes out through the axle
block is essentially a giant like one
inch thick aluminum rod going straight
to the center
we have two heat sources we have to
worry about in the vest oh I mean yes
well okay yes uh you're talking about
the controller the mosfets inside the
controller where all the current
actually pumps through those things also
get hot and so yeah you keep track of
the heat of your motor and the heat of
your mosfet depends on what app you're
using if you're using the the float
wheel app well okay actually let's
return to our little journey here yeah
we've got our brain screwed to our rails
we've got our battery in the Box screwed
to our rails got a motor there's not
much you can do you either get a hyper
cord motor you get a super super flux
motor
and you screw it to your rails and you
plug it in like that's all you do you
screw to your rails and you plug it in
sure okay now the last thing you need is
your foot pads you screw the one on the
battery on top of the battery just screw
onto the rails done now the one in the
front it's going to be one of the switch
there's a plug you plug it into the
brain box and you screw it onto the
rails it's that simple oh bumpers too
guess what you screw them onto the rails
now you're done you're one wheel you're
sorry you're a vesque your vest has been
built
but physically it's physically
physically it's done so the next step is
software so there's a lot of in-depth
tutorials on this but I'm going to help
give people an overview here so the
first thing that you're going to end up
doing is you're going to need to
calibrate it so you're going to get your
vesk app you can run it on your phone
it's called vesk tool vesk tool yep and
it's a super janky app is it through
test flight or it's no it's an app you
can get it's just the iOS version of it
sure sucks fix it please
you fix it it's on the source I know I'm
just being salty Hey listen my vet the
vest tool disconnects from my one wheel
every like five or ten seconds so it's
very difficult for me to change settings
yep so you hey hands up everybody if
you're on an iPhone because of the iOS
and apple it disconnects from the
Bluetooth consistently and then
reconnects instantly on the vesk tools
just be aware that you're going to be
working and it's going to pop out and
pop back in and pop out and pop back in
that's how it is
you just have to live with it and it's
fine I'm I'm exaggerating it's not that
big of it on Android that doesn't happen
and if you use a laptop that doesn't
happen
um now it's worth mentioning though if
you try to use a Windows laptop to
connect the Bluetooth in your brain uh
the the vesque on your board that's also
not going to work if you want to connect
to your vesk from a Windows based laptop
when you connect to it first you connect
to the vesk using your phone's Bluetooth
and there's a little box that you check
at the bottom which is I think it's like
TCP link or something like that or port
forwarding you check that box and then
on your computer you'll go to your Wi-Fi
that the phone is on and you'll type in
the the IP address of your phone and
then you can connect to your best okay
yeah it's it's convolutely it's a little
complicated but it's not that
complicated right but we didn't describe
ourselves with the phone yeah we did all
of our stuff with the phone so you don't
need to use a computer
um unless you're updating the firmware
or iPhone yeah if you have an Android
phone you can update the firmware from
your phone but on iOS you can't
um anyways so you're going to basically
turn on your vesk you're going to not
have it on the ground so the wheel can
spin a freely so like put put it on like
you know a testy level yeah it has to be
level put it like you know so the tail
in the front are like on two chairs
yep something or it's ideally the same
height on each side and you put on flat
ground and you're going to run a motor
calibration and it's going to see how
much current it takes to spin the motor
and what the resistance is and that kind
of stuff the next thing you're going to
do is there's a little IMU an inertial
motion sensing unit in the vest inertial
measurements inertial measurement units
initial measurement inertial measurement
unit initial measurement unit and that's
going to basically that's the thing that
tells the one wheel which direction it's
facing or is it tilted Etc that needs to
be calibrated as well so that it's
pointing the correct direction because
if you mount the vest upside down onto
the lid well the IMU is flipped upside
down likewise when you plug in your
motor
it doesn't know which way the motor's
spinning yet right so it's just going to
spin the motor and hope that it's the
right way and you're going to tell it
yes that's the right way or no reverse
the motor right so there's a couple
steps here you're going to make sure
your IMU is calibrated and it's flat and
it's oriented correctly so if your IMU
has been mounted upside down you're
going to then rotate you know you're
going to offset it by 180 degrees
rotation to flip it back over right
likewise you have to have the motor
calibrated to understand how much
current it's going to draw from the
system
there's guides for all the stuff it's
really not that complicated the overview
of all you're trying to do is trying to
make sure that IMU is aligning itself
correctly with the one wheel so that
it's flat and straight when the one
wheel is flat and straight you're trying
to make sure the vesk the electronic
speed controller knows how to
communicate with the motor and how much
energy it needs to communicate with the
motor and you basically run a
calibration one thing you run a
calibration from the other thing you
dial on some offsets if you need to call
it a day you're basically good to go
after that you have to tell it what's
the current level to turn on and off for
the foot pads which is about three volts
um not the current but like uh you're
talking about the the sensor fault state
yeah no no when you not the false State
the yeah yeah
there's three results it's when you when
you when you step up this is not current
what are you sorry not current voltage
when you step on the sensors on the
front foot pad there's two there's a
sensor on each side they put out voltage
when they're under tension and it's like
3.2 volts so you're going to go into the
app and say if you get more than three
volts
consider somebody on the sensor
at that point you're into tweaking
you're one wheel
um you're into putting in the settings
now what are the mains no there's a
bunch of settings like literally a
hundred different settings and that's
overwhelming it's overwhelming but you
don't need to mess with most of them
correct in fact you're going to follow a
guide to do your initial setups with how
much current you use Etc just follow a
guide if you get questions post
questions on pv.ev or the Facebook group
right straightforward I think there's
also a Discord but I never go there
um
all you're really going to mess with at
the end of the day is your P value your
I value and your D value for balance and
then the Mahoney KP
which is when we talk about our vests it
makes it sound super cool so like yeah
you know I set my P value to like 26.5
but once I drop the Mahoney down to like
1.9 it gave me a real stiff ride which
is what I was looking for okay
do you prefer I prefer my rides a little
bit less stiff so I'll drop my p-value
down to like say like 22 and maybe bump
The Cape the Mahoney KP up to like 2.0
maybe 2.1 yeah so is Mahoney a I'm not
exactly sure I think it's a name it's a
person it's a person it's someone's name
and they live inside of every uh uh I
think the mathematician that invented
this like filter for us okay it's a yeah
it's a type of processing motor okay so
what are we saying here basically
when it comes to a self-balancing device
it's going to use a PID Loop to bounce
now a PID Loop is a it's everything from
running the air conditioning in your
house the balance on your one wheel to
like you know the charge of a battery
the water going into your your garden
with a sensing like water system
all it is is you're saying Hey I want to
be flat okay I want the board to be flat
and when it stops being when like when
you start tilting it you're you're
introducing an error right I want it to
be at zero now it's at negative one or
it's at negative two or it's at negative
three
and so the p-value is going to say how
big is that error
and I'm going to give the same
proportional amount back into the motor
to fix that sure or you know if it was
your air conditioning
it would turn on your air conditioning
buy a lot or a little you know the
p-value is going to influence that right
so
the p-value is basically going to be how
hard is your board going to fight to
stay level as you as you ride so if you
want a stiffer ride you're going to
raise that p-value up
now the I value is basically error over
time so let's say you're on your board
and you tilt it just a scotch right
you're like a sketch a sketch you're at
negative 0.05 instead of negative 1
you're at negative 0.05 degrees of tilt
but you're like I'm at negative 0.05
degrees of tilt I want to be flat I
don't want to be at negative 0.05
degrees but if you're relying on the
p-value it's only giving you negative
0.05 degrees worth of power so it's not
enough to bring it back so what the I
value does it's going to add up that
little bit of error over time so like
every tick every refresh rate that is
still there adds and ads and ads and ads
until that number starts to become
bigger and that number is the amount of
power coming back in and then eventually
it's going to push it back up okay okay
then finally the D value is dampening
it's going to kind of like try to slow
everything down and that's actually
obsolete now
so it's just a p i value
um technically the d stands for
derivative not damping but in essence in
practice it's just damping the yeah it's
it's also not obsolete if you go into
like an older version of basically
set it to like 500.
or zero you'll be fine
um it's like I write the p-value of 26 I
write with an i value of 0.15 and I
write with d value of 500 Ren I think
well let me just double check come on
you just don't know how to stop your
head
open enthusiasm value is I think 24 is I
value is 0.25 imposter
um I think this means I get your vest I
okay and then there's this other value
called the Mahoney
okay I'm at 21.8 for my p-value my I is
0.25 and my D is 1500 yep
um and I I keep going back and forth
between adjusting my I value to like
0.05 and point like four five in that
range and it does change how it responds
to like really consistently pressing it
forward and it's weird I haven't decided
what I like
but I have settled on 21.8 for my
p-value and my Mahoney KP of something
but what is it so the Mahoney value
right so this is this weird thing that's
often another menu and honest was like
kind of the first one to really delve
into it
and it's basically so I'm not a
mathematician I've read the formula I
tried to walk through it I'm probably
going to get it wrong please correct me
in the comments if I get it wrong but
basically the Mahoney is a filter that's
basically going to estimate a position
and then measure it based off an actual
position and my understanding of what
happens when you turn this up my
understanding what happens is the
Mahoney filter is estimating your
position off of the inertia sensors in
the in the uh vesque rather than the
gyroscope so it measures off the inertia
sensors and then it uses the gyroscopes
to double check if it goes right or
wrong and then you know kind of that's
your error rate between the two
um and what it feels like it does is you
know when you're on your one wheel and
your one wheel is flat it's it only
knows it's flat because it's measuring
it versus like gravity right and when
you're accelerating
you know your up and down Vector of like
gravity changes a little bit you know
because you're adding some some push
forwards or some push backwards if
you're accelerating or decelerating
and so by turning up that Mahoney value
you're letting it offset like that up
Vector to kind of match what your
inertia is giving you okay so rather
than like decelerating the board just
stays flat and it feels kind of weird
like if like lean backwards the board
stays flat because technically up is
still just up it's going to be like well
up was up but based on our inertia
movement based on the fact that you're
decelerating what feels like up to you
is actually just tilted back a little
bit sure and it's going to tilt the
board back a little bit so when you
raise the Mahoney value what's going to
happen is when you accelerate the
board's going to lean forward when you
decelerate the board's going to gently
lean back it's gonna be this nice gentle
almost like waterbed style feeling and
when you're doing like intense trail
riding and you want the board to be a
little stiffer and like hold its Flat
Point more you're going to lower the K
the Mahoney KP value and likewise you
raise it if you want a really flowy
surfy Carvey kind of feel okay there are
other things to change the app beyond
that they're actually pretty
self-explanatory like there's a lot of
like tune modifications yeah the tune
modifiers are what I have the most fun
changing so and I don't we should
actually get into those right now that's
fine because like but like as a as a
general sort of thing no
no no it is really what most of the tone
uh tune modifiers do depending on
various uh situations like are you
accelerating really hard are you pulling
a lot of currents torque till is
something that will lift the nose as you
draw more and more current and so that's
how I'm able to climb those crazy steep
hills because the battery motor are
capable of doing it but normally the
nose would just hit the the ground and
then you can't go any further sure so
there's a way to basically tell it like
as it detects more current being pulled
make the assumption that you're going up
a hill therefore lift the nose and just
as like a default like lifting it
as you go up more and more you can also
do that based on your speed and then you
can also how much programming faults so
it's like before once the once you sense
I'm below say 66 volts on my battery
just raise the board up and write it
Captain Morgan style AKA pushback right
sure or if it's at a certain temperature
or if this you know there's a whole lot
of things at a certain speed you can
raise the board up
um so there's all these things in place
that you can tune to have it kind of
like talk to you to have it ride
different but when you're starting out
don't have any of that on I mean I have
your fault sensors like turned on and
stuff but like just PID value yeah boost
I don't even use boost at all I turned
torque tilt on a little bit for normal
riding and I'll like crank it when I
really need to like climb something I do
like turn tilt I love turn tilt which is
something that I really wish feature
motion Incorporated more in the GT what
we're touching on here is one of the
beauties of vesque and that is the
tweaking now some people I don't want to
tweak all the time and I'm gonna put
this out there I haven't touched my
board settings for two weeks okay I like
my settings and I haven't had to tweak
and I've gone on multiple rides in
different environments and I love how
it's writing because yeah a stock gt
usually has like maybe there are five
built-in modes and then custom shaping
that will happen someday at some point
and those uh don't give you you know
it's like uh uh it's a one button push
to this solution yes and the preset is
just a selection of settings in a
specific way and you hit a preset it'll
change all of those settings at once
right now there is no preset
functionality with vesk that's easy
there is technically I think it's called
meter metr uh but it's like a 50 module
like a Bluetooth module even though it
already has Bluetooth that you got to
buy and get its own app for it and that
allows you to save profiles of all your
different settings onto that chip so
then you can like change it out one of
the cool settings that vesk allows that
future motion just doesn't do is the
ability to allow it to balance
vertically which is it you look at it
like this is impossible this shouldn't
be possible at all and like yeah but
like it's just simple physics
um right now I can't just turn that on
because I only have my one setting and a
backup of that one setting so what I had
for a while anytime I I turn on the
vertical thing I back up the settings
that allow it to ride like a one wheel
and then I will install the the XML file
from a laptop to make it stand
vertically and it's like great cool
party trick I can't write it like this
though because you literally tell the
IMU that it is night to balance when
it's 90 degrees offset so your little
really changing its up position
essentially by 90 degrees
so it does not function at all as a
regular one-wheel when you do that and I
have to like it's a one-way trip I can
restore the settings but I can't
unrestore the settings yep
yeah so there's lots to play with
there's lots to Tinker with and tweak
but you will be able to dial in a ride
that's exactly what you want much more
so than you can with a future motion one
wheel on the flip side if you don't want
to Tinker at all obviously this isn't
the weight route you should go but that
said like I don't necessarily like to
Tinker a lot I like to Tinker to get my
stuff dialed in where I want it then I
want to be locked in Forever where it is
like when I set up my drum set I spend a
lot of time getting everything in the
right spot and I put down tape on the
carpet it's like nobody move my stuff
sure right sure and to be fair the
vesque is at the point now where I
believe you can get there where once you
dial in your settings you can just not
touch it and enjoy your wheel you don't
have to sit there and tweak it on every
single ride but I do like being able to
switch like on on the XR or the or the
GT you have response aggressiveness
profiles essentially and those are the
presets that you get like on the GT you
have flow which I love and you also have
Highline and then Apex basically it's
there it's a spectrum of aggression how
hard does says the one will try to get
underneath you are you a doom loading
screen or are you a doom like boss
battle right
um I was I was trying to make a loading
screen record no I got the reference I
just don't get the loadings anyway flow
allows you to fall a little bit before
it tries to get underneath you same
thing as like mission on the XR
versus delirium which is like Apex on
the GT
-ish don't correct me on this I can't I
don't care
um
yeah and so you know uh a more looser
board with less aggression will actually
like kind of let you lean forward and
back and that's what uh people have
called like that floating effect it
feels like you're floating it's really
carving but when you get more aggressive
it tries harder to keep the board level
delirium Apex they basically don't let
the board
tilt it off when you lean forward and
accelerate the board is still more or
less level
and
that's what the aggression comes from so
when you have it really aggressive it
also consumes way more energy too so
your battery doesn't last as long so if
you're running low on battery on an XR
switch to Mission if you're on a GT
switch it to flow and you'll be able to
squeeze out a little bit more range yep
so you get into the software point at
this point you know you're using your
phone to modify things
oh yeah there's a million different
guides a million different points of
view on it but at the end of the day you
get to just tweak and it's going to ride
okay just with basic settings you get to
mess with it from there and believe it
or not that's it that's building a vest
I know it's like a two hour long podcast
but at the end of the day it's build a
brain it's pretty straightforward get a
battery a little less straightforward
but hopefully more straightforward in
the future
put it into a frame
pretty straightforward
get your motor calibrated that part's
pretty straightforward get your IMU
calibrated a little less straightforward
but follow a guide watch a video online
um once again surf dotto's YouTube
channel amazing things there uh and
after that you're just putting in
settings to make it right how you want
to ride and that's basically it total
build time uh from from the point that
you add to deconstructed an XR to
it is now here and functional two days
uh it took us two days to get it up and
running but the first day was entirely
for getting the battery going yeah I
understand
and just filing and yeah okay if you
have all the parts on hand you can
theoretically do it in one day but I'm
gonna say two days okay yeah
it's really not that bad it's very
approachable
um it's a matter of like you know having
an overview like what this podcast will
give and then knowing to look at the
exact guides when they pop up and then
asking for help when you need it sure
um it's incredible incredibly helpful
people out there this is an open source
thing right so the open source movement
if something's wrong and it's broken
don't complain about it because nobody's
getting paid to fix it you have to fix
it yeah fix the app
if you don't like it fix it and if you
can't fix it
then help somebody else fix it yeah you
know and complaining to them isn't
helping them right yeah trying to
provide like specific feedback on what
isn't working how you think it should be
working and maybe like stuff the issue
yeah yeah yeah yeah try to be
constructive about it
um I want to talk about the super Flex
motor again real quick this is the motor
that is made by fungeneers they're the
ones who made our Thunder rails which we
love the Thunder rails I currently have
mine you notice like the six dots on the
side of it you'll have to scr I put my
one wheel down you'll have to scrub
earlier in the video to see it there's
two axle bolts and
it allows you to lower or raise the
board I am working on really cool
snowboarding Halloween costume right now
so I have it lifted as high as it'll go
that is a tangent the superflex motor
part of the struggle of like making a
video like this is that you know people
can get excited and want to get into
this stuff but like you know we makerspv
he's making these kits as fast as he can
but like the supply isn't quite there
the battery like try batteries the
batteries are sold out the kits are sold
out the motors
which is why I'm getting on uh talking
about the superflex motor they they did
two batches and we're in the first batch
and I just texted you this morning that
we got our shipping uh tracking number
for the motors so we should be getting
those in the next week or so very
excited for it and then there's going to
be a whole journey of actually getting
that connected to the vest because it's
new plugs we gotta solder some stuff get
various things my point is that do not
be surprised if any of these components
are difficult to acquire but do not lose
patience you know like the superflex
motor uh he told me uh
when when I bought them
that we should be getting them in in
like a couple weeks that was three
months ago I mean all supply lines right
now and we were in the first batch of
like 50 Motors and then there's another
batch of I think either 50 or 100 Motors
and they're just getting through those
first but like we're talking like
there's not many of these out there
right now hopefully eventually there
will be a decent Supply uh talking with
one of the guys uh from Oak City over
the at float life Fest uh last month
uh they're dreaming of a world where you
can walk into a store and just look at
all the different components that you
want and be able to build your own cus
and have help building your own custom
uh vesque in that store
but until like the supply can actually
meet that we can't do that another thing
is that you cannot actually sell a fully
constructed one-wheel device because of
the patents that future motion holds and
they will enforce them and they have
every right to enforce every right yeah
I'm not I don't have any problem with
that I and so it's like
yeah that's the only reason the vest
movement exists is because it's open
source because it's people doing it out
of the charitable kindness of their
hearts and when you enter that space
It's a Wonderful space but keep in mind
that's that's the space that you enter
as well and ideally you're bringing that
attitude as well so I think to wrap this
up let's talk about resources again here
pev.dev is the Forum to go or a lot of
stuff to talk to the people who are
actively building the things that you
are going to be putting into your vesque
uh there's like dozens of us there now
there's dozens of us
um the one wheel or sorry the the vesque
one wheel Builders Facebook group
um another great resource of course it's
Facebook I hate Facebook also Facebook
groups just kind of like feeds just fall
off the page I literally do not use
Facebook at all anymore and so a lot of
these resources are on Facebook it's
very frustrating because it's like I
feel like I'm missing out on news that
comes out on on various things of the
Facebook Marketplace is actually quite
good for for one wheel products it's
it's actually quite good so it's worth
it's worth checking out this Facebook
group and especially if you want to talk
to or reach out to anybody
um you need help building something you
need to get a part like I said can't
find a battery if you post hey I'm
looking I'm asking somebody to build me
an 18 cell battery with a BMS somebody
will probably I'll do it
like yeah obviously it's going to cost
you smarter sure it ain't gonna be free
and you're not gonna get it in two days
but like and it probably won't be cheap
but it's there you know it's there it's
option or even I want to build the
battery I guess can anybody help me like
you'll find resources right God man I
was so we're not doing the Enduro race
[Laughter]
um so pv.dv for the forums the one we'll
uh vesque one-wheel Builders Facebook
group there is a Discord I have not been
there I went and looked I didn't
recognize anybody that I know like in
the best space I didn't see dotto or Max
or like so I can't vouch for it they
might be on the engineers Discord
Channel perhaps I've seen I mean they
are on the engineers I've seen them
there I've interacted there I haven't
really been on screen check out the
functions Discord I guess but start with
PVE in the Facebook group
um in regards to your parts makers pev
is going to be your Holy Grail here in
America uh in Europe you're looking at
flow glider
um in fact makers PV is like symbiotic
with flow glider if you're going to buy
stuff for makers pev you're gonna have
to buy stuff from flow glider because
they're the ones that sell the lid to
all the pieces and the kit for makers
pev of course you can get the
self-assembled brain wonderful but all
the cases sells those parts from flow
glider on their site too right uh not
the lids
um and maybe that's a patent thing to
make sure the pieces are really separate
sure
um either way
um everything you need brain wise
Electronics wise makers pev and that's
complemented by flow glider and then of
course if you're like more 3D printed
enclosures check out lit Timber but
obviously hop on the Facebook group
there's you know there's options all
over the place
yeah other than that you get a used XR
for your pieces it doesn't hurt
um if you can afford it do you have one
and then I mean yeah just yeah that's
kind of it exercise safety you know
exercise caution
sorry
surfedato's YouTube channel watch all
the videos that came out in the past
three months just watch them all like
every single tutorial how to use the app
it's all there he does a great job
explaining it uh even how to set up the
BMS in the cbecso oh my God his video
so reason why the the batteries went we
don't know if that's why we don't but uh
yeah
the BMS with the the cbcso wasn't
correctly uh set up
basically there it's there to protect
the battery from being
damaged sure one of those types of
damage is overcharging and it'll shut
the battery off or The Terminal will
literally be disconnected so that you do
not overcharge the battery the problem
is that
the one wheel
when you decelerate when you decelerate
it's regening it's it it doesn't have a
physical break it only has regen braking
and so when your battery is full you
cannot regen which is why you can't go
down a hill when you freshly unplug the
one wheel and if you do it'll start like
leaning back on you and eventually shut
off and
like that do what that water bottle just
dramatically did Clint killed his one
wheel doing that
yeah it overcharged and something burned
out on it he had to send it and get
fixed but uh so the cbcso had a thing
where that that overcharge just cut off
like the emergency freaking eject button
was a little too low it's set to 85
volts and the board charges to 84 volts
so if you brake kind of hard you cross
the thresh
that's like 86 volts and I'm obviously
I'm very careful when riding the full
wheel too because like yeah sure full
charge battery but yeah so back to
resources here Maker's pev for your
brain Parts
um check out the torque pack in the
torque box yeah badgerwheel.com they got
their start uh basically making
waterproofing kits yep for the one
pillow glider
um for the rest of your parts uh fun
wheel is that fun wheel ah float life
for rails and foot pads bumpers fenders
yeah they have their own products as
well that are very good foot pads they
make very good rear foot pads float life
and Craftsman ride are for everything
non-electronic wheel yep if you want to
customize it or tires yeah exactly oh
yeah they're really into the like the
sidekicks I don't know what the the
names are varies also I don't think
we've thrown them out yet but uh maybe a
good replacement for your light uh that
you're going to lose upon vesting are
shred lights I love shred lights it's my
main light I use is there like I think
they're 800. their homies and uh yeah
make a good product so yeah yeah yep and
then uh
and that's oh and then finally for
Batteries chai Battery Systems of course
uh or JW batteries or JW batteries
um if they still make batteries and
we're going to have links for all the
stuff down in the description below plus
other places you might be able to look
for some of these things
and that's pretty much it that's it go
out and build some vests tell us what
you did share it with us share with
other people yeah I want to see them
builds I want to see them build if you
guys have Tech know-how please also
bring that to the group if you're
somebody that can actually build
batteries or wants to work with somebody
else make a standardized battery with
BMS and box enclosure that fits in the
XR platform and fits like please please
you're not only going to make vesks more
accessible for us can make them more
accessible for everybody so let's all
join together let's all contribute and
let's make it so that we can build our
own open source single wheeled riding
platform but here's the thing though is
that like I mean yes but it also opens
up so many doors on what a one wheel is
yeah something you know one with like a
24 inch tire yeah
I don't know I I have all suddenly I
have all these ideas what would a one
wheel look like if instead of the
standard length rails they were twice as
long like it's probably not good
um I'm kind of doing that with my
snowboard uh costume project but uh like
I was also thinking
a one-wheeled stool what if you take the
foot pads and just put them on top of
each other above the one wheel tires
a little yeah sure like stool type deals
I mean kind of but like
kind of
it doesn't matter my point is that like
it could be anything and so like I have
all these different ideas for projects
that you know aren't compatible with the
standard blueprint of a one wheel yeah
you don't you don't need to use the
hypercore motor or the superflex motor
either you can use any drone motor
that's this big if you want in fact the
vesque which is in the mobile you
probably couldn't can fly a drone you
can power an e-bike can handle
electronic skateboard can build a Segway
can build a hoverboard the vest can do
almost anything that requires electronic
speed control not just one Wheels oh
yeah so the Enduro race is November 5th
here in La uh which is probably still
before
it's probably still in the future if
you're listening to this podcast the day
it came out
um I was originally going to participate
uh
because I want to use a vesque and
basically throw in a 60 mile battery
because it's a 50 mile race I want to be
able to have just a battery that I
didn't have to charge because the Enduro
race is 50 miles everyone racing has has
to stop and strategically charge that
you know that other contestants chains
and whips out ready to go super
intrigued by the race I really wanted
for pit stopping yeah so I was like if I
don't have to stop to charge that's a
huge leg Yeah so I was talking with like
the guys organizing and they're like we
might not allow that I'm like okay well
in that case I'm not even gonna try it's
gonna take a lot of effort for me to
because I wanted to basically build an
entire extra big battery pack that I
could put in my my backpack and have a
wire going down to run in parallel with
the battery inside the one wheel so if
it unplugs it doesn't just die on me and
once again that's the beauty of the vest
yeah you can do all that so yeah if
you're out there with an XR an old XR or
broken XR or you don't even have an XR
but you want to get into vesks like Jump
On In come join us
come join us on the forums come join us
in the Facebook group and start building
and enjoy the process it's super cool
dude that the newest firmware update
literally was game changing it literally
changed everything's doing drops off of
picnic tables he's writing down Cliffs
I'm not joking he is riding down Cliffs
he only made it halfway uh he ran down
the rest of it there are certain parts
where I was like really really Steep and
I'm able to just ride down it like it
was nothing I think part of that was
because I have my rails lifted and it
gave me extra tail clearance yeah but
that's a part of vest yeah the night of
the firmware update you were hitting
things without even thinking about them
that like are very high level moves and
there was no like well it's not a vest
this might not work which is when I was
riding my vest like when we did the
steakhouse ride it was like I don't know
if the vest can handle this it's gonna
be squirrely of course it did go off the
edge at one point yeah uh we managed to
get it back even though I didn't have
lights on it well dude uh one of my
friends from Gravity Industries came
over uh I took him on a one-wheel ride
and I had two GTs on my desk it was
perfect and so I had both of them on the
GTS and I was riding the vesque but
anytime I wanted to like show off and do
something cool I'd be like hey can I
ride that for a moment I would get off
of the vest and get on the GT to do like
this two foot drop of course because
there was no way in hell I was gonna do
that on the confidence right now it's
yeah easy on a vest it just handles it
it's fine yeah I found myself more
invigorated and excited about one
Wheeling than I've been in in quite a
while and that's saying something
because I am always invigorated and
excited about one-wheeling I felt times
it felt like when I first got a one
wheel again wow yeah like I was hitting
you up like every night oh yeah yeah
yeah so yes I hope this podcast was
useful for everybody uh come join us in
the open source movement like I've got a
taste of it from the AI space now and
now I'm getting in the one wheel space
it's wonderful I love it so yeah come
make some vests with us come crush some
Gnar uh just Crush that Nar Nar with us
yeah and I yeah and just to like as an
endnote I want to reiterate don't hate
on future motion like don't use this as
like oh I hope they go on the ground
one wheel anymore it's like I want us
all to live as in a symbiotic
relationship yeah if there's anything
I've learned from the vesque it's just
how nice the GTO
it gave me a new appreciation for how
good the firmware on a one wheel is yeah
that's what's gonna happen to you too
you're gonna build these wheels and be
like dang the XR is a beautiful machine
the GT it's a beautiful machine these
are such nice machines
but they're like the MacBooks to the PC
that you're about to build yourself yeah
yeah because I I want to maintain a
relationship with future motion and I
was very hesitant about doing this
podcast because I worried that this
would hinder that we the last podcast we
did because I had a bunch of things that
I had said uh they wanted to address
those things before they brought me on
to be a uh commentator a commentator for
race the rail and I didn't get to be a
commentator because of some of the
things I said on this podcast so I was
very concerned I got to be an
uncommentator yeah but there's no hard
feelings that it was it was a bit of a
miscommunications and problems and stuff
like that they're super busy I no hate
on them for any of that I'm not no hard
feelings either I would love to be able
to go on their podcast here soon too I
just have no weekends free for the next
month so it's been very difficult I
think and I guess fear of mine this
podcast we're doing right now might
create a thing where I don't get to be
on that podcast with them well if you
would just stop accusing them of being
reptilians for like two seconds
do you not see their slits for eyes
yeah so I if I'm hoping to join the one
wheel podcast at some point before the
end of the year I hope to make it happen
we've talked I've talked with them about
doing it I hope it happens uh just a
matter of finding time to drive up there
and doing it cheers and my hope is that
by us making this podcast for the vesque
we're spreading more awareness getting
more people into the space increasing
the amount of people contributing to the
project so that in a few months time we
see a more standardized system easier
access more people to build them better
Parts availability more people out there
crushing Gnar hey like I would love all
that and hopefully it takes some of the
pressure off of all of us going into
future motion be like please make this
wheel for me that I need it I need it to
be like this for me and now you can be
like well actually no don't worry about
it I'll make it for me you know you guys
keep making the GT it's a beautiful
machine never run one wheel before go
buy a go buy a future motion machine
first they're great for the rest of us
yeah I I
if you have no one will experience
you're gonna have not a great time
getting into vest yeah you're gonna have
no idea what it should ride like yeah
yeah yeah because I see people who are
doing exactly that and they're like
I'm like you don't know what it should
ride like oh no the one wheel is the
gold standard for what a self-balancing
device should ride like I frankly think
everyone should start on a V1 just to
learn like you're just to learn your
foot placement and foot control like
yeah oh there's nothing like a V1
that'll teach you that because Cliff
still rides around on the V1 and I went
riding with him last Saturday night it's
so fast how is he so fast he's faster
than us on a mountain ride and we run
XRS and he's on his V1 we also weighs a
lot less than us true the smaller dude
yeah he's he's got which I've found is
there's a very direct correlation
between uh yeah well yeah like one of
the guys that uh float life Fest named
Nico is a smaller dude doesn't weigh as
much and he was able to hit 33 miles an
hour on his best before the recent
firmware update wow wow what oh speaking
of miles an hour it's worth pointing out
too that when the firmware update came
out I set my personal oh my lifetime top
speed that morning good job same with me
I had I'd gone half a mile before I hit
an all-time vesque record personally oh
yeah I mean the day before I had set a
personal all-time speed record of 27
miles an hour on the GT and then the
next day don't forget I had never gone
above like 15 miles an hour on the vest
because it would get like too shaking
I'm like I don't want to have to run
this out sure because I feel like that's
going to happen and then I was like cool
I got the firmware updated went down the
street I looked at my phone was like you
just went 24 miles an hour I was like
what
and you also you are you've never really
been a speed demon in America I'm not a
speed demon at all and and like you're
cruising like you're pushing it when
you're hitting like 19 or 20 miles an
hour and you just hit 24 like it was
nothing yeah that's how nice these are
also there's no pushback to tell you
that you're going fast I wouldn't have
hit it I have pushback turned on my
board my duty cycle is well below it
like I was I was good I could I mean so
your pushback is based off of duty cycle
rather than speed
yes because you can you can change that
yeah currently a set to duty cycle
that's actually something I uh uh I I
would really love that's uh the GT
pushback is pretty aggressive and in
times that you when you're going
downhill you can pick up speeds so much
faster than uh uh yeah than you even
realize and the last thing I want when
you have an angle uh is is your tail
suddenly going toward the ground it's
like well the initial firmware on the GT
that was a much bigger problem right
they actually came out with a huge
overhaul on the firmware a few months
after the GTA still notice it though I
mean I mean it's hilarious yeah yeah
but I could hit 30 miles an hour my best
confident if I wanted to I
might get there eventually I was at 65
duty cycle at 24 miles an hour I could
easily hit 30 especially on a slide
downhill
but I'm not gonna yeah Ivy if you're
listening don't worry
all right well gentlemen I have to get
home sure yeah this was a longer podcast
we are officially at two hours now this
is a very important podcast for me
because I mean just like you we've been
talking about doing it for a long time
yeah we're still talking about doing an
actual like Corridor crew video
something but like finding the right
idea hasn't really popped up yet I
thought maybe making us like a 50 or 60
mile like battery for a race might be
the thing but yeah we'll see so it goes
so we're gonna go camping instead
all right everybody thanks for listening
I look forward to reading the comments
in this one uh yeah yeah yeah good good
yeah maybe the comments section of this
video can be a resource too yeah uh if
people have any questions or information
yeah yeah
um yeah share your stories
yeah I would love to see your comments
from dotto and Max and all those other
guys it'd be cool
oh also uh and Jimmy Chang who uh on our
last podcast made a re-edit of that
um and I was a little frustrated because
it's like it takes some of the words I
said out of context and whatnot but like
what are you gonna do
um yep no it's fine he ended up he did
take it down though or no he did he take
it down He adjusted it which I uh you
know I guess I'm just trying to say
there's no hard feelings on that a lot
of other people were angry on our behalf
I guess and to those people it's cool
don't worry about it Jimmy's a cool guy
all right so long everybody
and three two one